en fait j'attends que cette manière de
travailler ensemble des mouches sur un
corpus idéologique il y a d'abord un
travail sur la ligne sur les valeurs
sûres ce qu'est la droite
la ligne politique que nous devons
essayer de construire et de tenir c'est
celle d'une droite qui assume clairement
ses convictions parce qu'à chaque fois
qu'on a regagné nos convictions
on a reculé mais la grande question
c'est que sommes nous capables de faire
une fois que nous gouvernons que nous
avons dit avant de gouverner
je n'ai pas essayé de gérer un peu mieux
la situation actuelle c'est d'anticiper
pur le monde futur autant un peu le coup
à tous ces clichés
[Musique]
vous nous avez dit la droite elle est
libérale et gaullistes sort d'où on
vient pour savoir où on va la france
vient du fond des âges est la même une
promesse d'éternité il faut qu'on trouve
la bonne façon d'avancer pour le dire
aux gens et on peut vraiment faire la
différence là dessus
[Musique]